with the growing outrage over the death
of dante wright in brooklyn center
minnesota for two nights in a row
there have been clashes between police
and protesters demanding justice for
wright
who was shot and killed by a police
officer during a traffic stop
newly released body cam footage shows
what unfolded police say the officer
involved
meant to reach for her taser and they're
calling it an accident
omar villafranca is in brooklyn center
minnesota for us omar good morning to
you we've been tracking the pictures
overnight
what's it like there this morning well
good morning it's quiet now but police
and national guard are still here after
another night of protest where about 40
people were arrested
we also now know a name the officer who
shot right
her name is kim potter she's a 26 year
veteran of the police department
and the police chief is telling us that
when she grabbed she meant to grab her
taser but instead
she grabbed her handgun my heart
is literally broken into a thousand and
i could never get that back
because of a mistake because of an
accident
at a vigil for her son dante wright's
mother remembered him as a funny and
playful father
those tributes echoed by chyna whitaker
the mother of wright's son
dante junior i didn't get to say goodbye
to him
and
just to see him again
[Applause]
as darkness fell on brooklyn center
clashes between protesters and police
continued outside their headquarters
the unrest followed the release of body
cam video
showing the moments leading up to
wright's death
after pulling right over for an expired
registration tag
officers learned he had an outstanding
warrant stemming from
two misdemeanor charges when the
officers tried to handcuff right
he struggled to get back in his car
that's officer kim potter yelling she
will tase right
but instead she's holding her gun which
she then
fires wright traveled a few blocks
before crashing into another car
he died at the scene brooklyn center
police chief
tim gannon from what i viewed and the
officer's reaction in distress
immediately after
that this was an accidental discharge
that resulted in a tragic death
of mr right i need to be transparent and
i want to be forthright
officer potter has been placed on
administrative leave
but some people are calling for her
badge including mayor mike
elliott we cannot afford to make
mistakes
that lead to the loss of life
of other people in our profession
president biden chimed in yesterday and
is urging protesters to remain calm and
peaceful and keep in mind this is all
happening
just a few miles from where the trial a
former police officer derek chovin
is facing murder charges for the killing
of george floyd
and we also learned that the wright
family and the floyd family are going to
have a joint press conference later on
this afternoon
anthony omar you mentioned that officer
kim potter is a 26-year veteran of the
force
what else do we know about her well as
we mentioned 26-year
veteran of the force and the star
tribune is also reporting that she
has been a police union boss and another
thing too is that she was a training
officer and was training another officer
that day
so one of the big questions that remains
is as a training officer
how could she not tell the difference
between a heavy loaded handgun
and a much lighter taser well that is
the question omar thank you very much